[Musique]
nos ressources naturelles comme l'air
l'eau les sols s'épuise se raréfient se
pollue la biodiversité s'effondrent les
espèces animales s'étaint en masse waouh
ça commence bien
qui dans cette salle pense qu'il faut
absolument sauver la nature
pouvez vous lever la main merci
bon bien moi je ne pense pas que ce soit
la priorité et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi
quand j'étais petit j'habitais une
maison à la campagne
imaginez les lézards gricourt et le long
des murs l'eau de la rivière était
fraîche on pouvait cueillir des mûres à
profusion dans les chemins creux
le soir les grillons fente à tue tête
les nuits étaient constellés des toiles
vous allez me dire quelle chance
eh bien je vais vous faire une
confidence
tout ce temps là je n'avais qu'une envie
le passé devant la télévision et c'est
fini un regret petit à petit à
l'intérieur alors savoure avait
peut-être quelque chose en éclusant suis
pas la seule
nous sommes une espèce volontairement
envoi de déconnexion de la nature une
première fois renner liman est en tout
cas devenus jeunes adultes
je le vis très bien j'ai vite et un
appartement un pain et j'étais
consultante à la défense en plein milieu
des tours dans les couloirs du bureau du
métro g
complètement absorbé dans les
conversations téléphoniques et mon
agenda surchargé
je tenais mon téléphone d'une main de
l'autre mais dossiers étaient pressés
vous imaginez des crayons des terreaux
c'était ça je le vivais très bien
jusqu'à ce mardi ensoleillé du mois de
juillet j'étais alors maman de deux
jeunes enfants
lorsque j'ai croisé cette femme dans les
couloirs du centre commercial elle était
complètement absorbé par ses
conversations téléphoniques
elle tenait son téléphone d'une main de
notre nez laisse elle était pressée et
moi eh bien moi je me suis arrêtée net
et est sidéré il y avait un enfant au
bout de la laisse
il devait avoir quatre ans et il ne se
pressait pas assez il voulait simplement
regardé ce qui se passait autour de lui
et elle elle tirer vraiment fort sur la
laisse elle ne le regardait pas vous
imaginer l'expérience pour cet enfant
sans aucun contact physique avec la
personne qui doit prendre soin de lui et
qui est présente et en même temps
prisonniers de cette laisse c'est ce
jour que j'ai compris l'urgence de la
situation de déconnecter de la nature
nous sommes passés à déconnecter des
autres nous vivons dans une société de
l'ubiquité nous sommes présents mais
nous ne sommes pas vraiment là nous
sommes ailleurs au téléphone partie sur
un réseau en ligne
coincé à l'intérieur d'un écran or cette
société l'ubiquité moins de rapprocher
les uns des autres
isole ses enfants car quand les adultes
préfèrent le virtuel au réel l'inerte
aux vivants lorsqu'ils ne s'intéressent
plus à la nature comment réagissent les
enfants de la même manière il se fixe à
l'intérieur des murs et des écrans
aujourd'hui en grande bretagne 74% des
enfants sort au quotidien - longtemps
qu'un détenu de prison
en france prenant une classe de 20
élèves huit d'entre eux ne sortent
jamais dehors en dehors de la cour de
récréation et dites moi si j'ai formé
une cour de récréation en france ça
ressemble à ça cet isolement
il est avant tout physique sensoriel car
à l'intérieur il y a peut apercevoir et
le peu qu'il y à est infiniment moins
subtile infiniment moins complexe que ce
que les enfants perçoivent dans leur
environnement naturel
quelle est l'odeur d'une vidéo la
texture d'un téléphone
alors oui à l'intérieur tout est lisse
confortable pratique mais les sens sont
à la diète
or cet isolement sensoriel provoque un
isolement émotionnelle car ce sont les
sensations qui déclenche les émotions
c'est le corps pas la tête
alors si en plus ce que les enfants
perçoivent n'est pas cohérent comme des
images ou des sons agressif alors qu'ils
sont installés comme vous dans un
fauteuil confortable et qui m'envoient
gâteau qui devrait délicieux et bien
c'est le désordre dans leurs émotions
ce qu'ils perçoivent est à la fois
disproportionnée et confus il ne décode
plus leurs émotions
ces messages pourtant indispensable pour
apprendre à se connaître soi apprendre à
se protéger et apprendre à réagir à son
environnement de manière adaptée
aujourd'hui les enfants en souffrent
déjà reprenons notre classe de 20 élèves
sept d'entre eux selon l'unicef sont en
souffrance psychologique 7 sur 20 on
sait que les enfants qui grandissent
dans des quartiers avec peu de nature
souffre jusqu'à six fois plus souvent de
troubles anxieux et de dépression mais
en fait c'est toute la société qui en
souffre déjà car ces enfants qui se
déconnecte de leurs émotions sont
logiquement de moins en moins capable de
comprendre celle des autres et donc de
se mettre de comprendre et de ressentir
eux-mêmes des émotions
face à la détresse de quelqu'un d'autre
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui sont 40 % moins
empathique que dans les années 80 la
professeure de psychologie
jean wenger a même trouvé un petit nom
les look at me regardez moi alors je
vous pose la question
nos enfants sont ils en train de perdre
leur part d'humanité
cette part qui les connaître aux autres
avec tout leur sens qui leur permet de
ressentir des émotions et d'y réagir de
fonctionner ensemble tout en restant eux
mêmes
cette part qui en fait des êtres
profondément sociaux sommes nous en
train d'élever une génération hors sol
complètement déconnecté du vivant des
organismes tous identiques dont
l'expérience est la même pour tous
quatre murs et un écran et qui vont
réaliser leurs tâches côte à côte sans
émotions sont touchés sans même se
regarder alors non il ne me semble pas
que nous allons sauver la nature
nous n'allons pas tous ensemble sauver
un milieu que nous ne connaissons plus
et que nous ne transmettons plus à nos
enfants
car comment cet enfant de 8 ans qui a
peur de marcher pieds nus dans l'herbe
et oui nous en sommes là comment
deviendra-t-il sept adultes qui s'ouvre
à la nature en revanche en revanche si
c'était la connexion à la nature qui
allait sauver les générations futures en
ravivant leur part d'humanité
j'ai pris conscience de la déconnexion
progressive des enfants ou plus simples
éléments naturels et des conséquences
pour eux et pour la société
je suis donc allé trouver des
professionnels de l'éducation et la
nature et ensemble nous avons créé une
académie nature dans amsterdam pour
offrir un espace temps dans le quotidien
des enfants et les connecter aux vivants
qu'est ce que la connexion à la nature
c'est une synergie profonde une relation
instinctive
si le petit knox était là il vous dira r
vous n'avez pas besoin de parler à la
nature elle est déjà en vous être
connecté à la nature c'est respirer
sentir ses épaules qui se relâche se
sentir chez soi enfin c'est le flou où
vous connaissez être dans la zone
cet état d'engagements et de
satisfaction de tout son être
comme clara à la regarder la imaginer là
pendant la demi-heure qui a précédé
cette photo être connecté à la nature
c'est une sensation physique d'être
intensément ou paisiblement vivant et ça
fait du bien
cette connexion et cette relation se
construit simplement en ménageant des
temps suffisamment régulier dans la
nature pour que les enfants s'y sentent
chez eux
alors attention parce que se retrouver
parachuté tout seul dans la nature c'est
un peu comme se retrouver sur une scène
avec un violon entre les mains sans
avoir jamais été initiés à la beauté de
la musique ça peut être déconcertant
voire carrément angoissant pour certains
alors non il ne s'agit pas de lâcher les
enfants dans la nature pour qu'il se
fatigue ni même de les surveiller
mais bien de les y accompagner être ce
médiateur bienveillant ce rôle modèle
qui aura à coeur de transmettre sa
propre connexion à la nature aux enfants
et de les y amener à vous et découvrir
vivre des aventures exprimer leur
sensibilité libérer leur créativité
coopérer rire s'émerveiller il y a
encore des adultes pour transmettre la
beauté de la musique l'amour du sport
les voix de l'arithmétique et oui c'est
important
il est si rare de voir des adultes
transmettre l'amour du vivant aux
enfants pourtant c'est le soc
et aujourd'hui cette transmission est
devenue une urgence pour préparer les
générations futures au monde de demain
car la connection à la nature permis de
réveiller chez les enfants deux
compétences dont nous avons tous besoin
c'est la résilience et l'empathie être
ancré dans ce que l'on est et savoir
revenir souplement savoir rester humain
face aux difficultés de la vie
savoir s'accommoder au monde sans
chercher à anéantir tout ce qui nous
dérange c'est la résilience et c'est une
compétence clé pour vivre heureux
alors oui c'est confortable est à
l'intérieur de sa maison ou de sa salle
de classe parce qu'on connaît tout son
environnement
tout est sous contrôle en revanche on ne
sait jamais totalement ce qu'on va
trouver dans la nature parce qu'elle est
riche c'est l'environnement
d'expérimentation le plus riche qui soit
il n'y a que la nature qui offre cette
diversité et cette profondeur à tous nos
sens et à l'offre en permanence une
multitude de changements
la plupart du temps un film parfois
conséquent les enfants perçoivent ces
changements avec tous leurs sens et ce
faisant ils sont obligés de s'y ajuster
en permanence alors ça peut être éviter
d'être ébloui par le reflet du soleil
sur l'eau ajuster son équilibre au
relief du terrain pour danser ou se
créer un abri exprès pour éviter une
bonne douche de plus froides et souvent
ne pas réussir à éviter tout à fait
lorsque luca sept ans nous a rejoints il
s'énervait souvent et nous disait est ce
qu'on ne peut pas marcher sur le chemin
comme le font les gens normaux
bon et bien luca en fait ils étaient
exaspérés
parce que les branches des arbres dans
les fourrés et bien ça l'agressait et
bien aujourd'hui lookin il ses confères
des branches des arbres
il est des corps il est taillé en flèche
et grimpe de dents il prend confiance en
lui il collectionne les expériences de
petites frustrations et de changement
ajustements et muscles ainsi
sa résilience il apprend à s'adapter aux
situations tout en conservant ce qui
fait sa personnalité d'enfants très
attachante sens résilience
on ne peut pas développer l'empathie on
ne peut pas se tourner vers l'autre si
on est trop occupé à se débattre avec
ses propres émotions
or l'empathie c'est la compétence qui
fait progresser l'humanité depuis
toujours l'être humain n'a jamais cessé
de se développer et de construire de
mettre ces savoirs en commun nous ne
réalisons jamais d'aussi grandes fosses
que lorsque nous nous comprenons pour
agir ensemble et dans la paix or nous
n'avons pas besoin de nous connaître
parfaitement pour nous comprendre
pas vrai alors comment ça fonctionne
dans la nature
tout arrive pour une raison tout a un
sens une explication à découvrir
c'est ce qui stimule la curiosité des
enfants les rangs enclins à se poser des
questions et déclenche la surprise
accompagné par un médiateur il
il s'intéresse à d'autres formes de vie
ils s'imaginent leur dialogue interne se
met à leur place
et là c'est gagné dans le froid humide
d'amsterdam
nous avons emmené sept classes à la
recherche des oiseaux de leur quartier
bon les pigeons les corneilles les
canards et bien ils ont découvert des
choses incroyables sur ces oiseaux qu'il
côtoyait pourtant tous les jours ils se
sont intéressés à leurs conditions de
vie en hiver on choisit les oiseaux
totem ont même essayé fabriquer leurs
propres ailes et bien les enfants ont
passé les jours suivants à se répéter le
nouveau code de conduite qu'ils avaient
convenu ensemble on ne donne pas de pain
à manger aux canards
parce que ça leur fait mal au ventre
alors lorsque les enfants sont capables
d'empathie pour des formes de vie aussi
différentes et éloignées que le sont les
canards ou les vers de terre comme pour
clara où cet arbre en bas de chez vous
développez et transposer ce réflexe
d'empathie pour cet étranger ou ce
voisin différents devient vraiment
un voeux d'enfants est en définitive un
enfant qui sera connecté à la nature
c'est un enfant qui ne fera jamais de
mal à la nature parce qu'il la respecte
trop pour ça imaginer un futur dans
lequel les adultes sont en prise avec
leur sens et ce qu'ils sont profondément
dans lequel il sauf naturellement
s'ouvrir aux autres êtres humains et aux
autres êtres vivants dans lequel ils
savent trouver les ressources en eau et
agissent spontanément pour préserver
leur nature cette relation instinctive
qui fait partie d'eux je crois qu offrir
un lien sincère avec la nature et entre
les êtres humains un lien à la vie est
l'un des plus grand cadeau que nous
puissions faire à nos enfants et au
monde alors je vais vous demander il
faut c'est tout simple à vous parents
professionnels de l'éducation
quand vous sortirez de cette salle tout
à l'heure posez vous la question quelle
place est ce que veulent s à la
connexion à la nature dans la vie des
enfants
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour lui
donner la place qu'elle mérite
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]